un cadavre dans le lac
ils l'ont repêché ce matin il a été vidé
comme un poisson vous avez une idée de
qui l'a coupé en deux et pourquoi il
s'enfuit de l'ambassade de chine qui on
le retrouve mort sur les berges du lac
vous trouvez pas ça curieux quelque
chose qui crachent sur cette histoire
qui émettent en train de creuser moi
c'est toujours ton ex mari qui fait le
sale boulot
aujourd'hui je vous annonce la création
de l' agence de protection de
l'australie qu'on soit pris en sandwich
entre deux superpuissances qui
refuseront tout les doutes de céder et
plasil et les états unis commencent à
faire des danses de guerre une photo de
notre ministre de la défense prochinois
prise il ya 20 ans refait surface
est ce qu'il ya eu des problèmes ou des
incidents diplomatiques cette loi
préconise en état policier avec vous aux
commandes telle une pente et affamé le
monde est très dangereux e mail on peut
pas se permettre d'être désinvolte en
matière de renseignement il est une
agence gouvernementale impliqués et un
ministres concernés
personne ne sait ce butin d'histoire bac
quelqu'un nous a vus on se voit pas on
se parle pas je n'ai aucune envie
d'aller mexique et en russie comme
edward snowden j'vous savoir dans quel
trou de souris vous l'avez acculé madame
d'intérêt ce n'était pas une attaque
c'était un message et les cimetières
politiques sont remplis de personnes
fidèles adhésion
tout ça c'est obligé je suis sûr que tu
me vois que certaines pièces du puzzle
tu verras jamais l'image entière
je crois que le pire c'est pour bientôt
je ne fais que chercher la vérité